when when it comes to your album uh i
saw the artwork uh the artwork is crazy
uh give me kind of like the whole
concept but behind the title and the
artwork
um
so this project is uh it's a sequel i
love doing sequels because i like movies
and [ __ ] so i feel like if it's a good
first movie like i want to see the
second one okay it's always like that so
i've been doing it my whole career just
making him a sequel this was like
if you look at the first cover it was
animated drawn out a bunch of chaos
almost where's waldo but you see a lot
of like trauma black issues and stuff
like that cops football players
basketball players people in jail and
then we decided to bring
this cover to live action to like to
real life so we got even like some of
the family members that represented some
of these places some of my sisters some
of my brothers my cousins my friends
and
and then just other people who just
could feel those roles and we brought it
to life and it's just kind of showing
like
even if you see like where i'm placed at
in the first one i'm kind of like on the
outside but i'm still close to the
center and this one i'm like dead in the
middle
it's kind of like representing like
where i see myself at this point in my
life you know what i'm saying yeah i
left
did all the touring and stuff made a
success of myself whatever my mom would
say
and um
when i come back it's kind of like i see
the same things you know what i'm saying
this is kind of like a representation of
my mindset
yeah i think chaos i think
i feel like artwork nowadays is like
very um
my i just feel like people don't put
enough thought into their [ __ ] well so
when i see like your [ __ ] i'm like damn
this this is crazy or so shout out to
you even like uh like a guy like
westside boogie his his artwork is was
crazy on his album crazy album too by
the way that's a boogie um